All right. Good evening, everyone.
Thank you so much for being here
for Advances in Precision Oncology.
Again, thank you so much for making it to this session, to Plenary Hall H.
And
pleased to introduce my co-chair, Dr.
Jenny Liu from Australia. Let
me head down to the podium.
I am Vivek Subbiah, a precision oncologist, a professor of medicine
at Stanford University.
Welcome to Advances in Precision Oncology, the clinical
trials mini symposium, presenting the latest and
greatest in precision oncology.
As you can see, this is a view of Earth from Artemis
II.
We are all here, NTEA, ACR, San Diego, the USA, the world,
all of us are here. This is the view of the Earth
from Artemis. As Reid Wiseman, the astronaut-aquanaut
from Artemis II says, "There are no words."
To get this view of Earth from the moon,
the crew had to make way
to a trip around the moon.
So this is astronomy. In oncology, we want to go to
the moon. We want to cure cancer,
the Moonshot Program.
So how do we get to the moon?
So we need to have a program,
a NASA program. We need to have rockets.
We need to have satellites to be launched.
So to the moon and back, the field needs to have a plan,
needs to have a roadmap, needs to have all these rockets
launched.
So
astronomers launch rockets to get to the
moon and Mars and beyond,
and oncologists launch targets.
ALK, ROS1, HER2,
EGFR, KRAS, NTRK, BRAF, BRCA,
and much more.
The Moonshot sets the destination.
Precision oncology charts the course
one genome at a time,
one patient at a time.
Each trial you will hear today is its own
mini version of a small NASA program for a specific
target,
exacting,
purposeful, and essential to the journey.
So you will be hearing about ROS1, HER2,
EGFR targets, KRAS G12C inhibition,
Fak inhibition,
PSMA, and folate receptor alpha.
So the work that remains is making sure
that the rocket has enough seats for everyone.
Thank you so much for being here.
So let's go. Okay, buckle your seats.
Thank you.
Thank you, Vivek. Thanks everybody for joining us.
So in this afternoon's session, we will be having seven
talks, each of 10 minutes, with five minutes of
question and answer. And I encourage everyone to use your
phones and to come up to the microphones to ask questions.
Unfortunately, our first speaker, Dr.
Haifeng Liu
is unfortunately unable to attend the conference at short notice, but
hopefully his slides will be available for everybody to
review afterwards. So for our first speaker, I'm very
pleased to introduce Professor Luda Bazhanova
from the UC San Diego Moores Cancer Center, San
Diego.
She will be presenting
on telatrexib in TKI-naive patients
with ROS1 non-small cell lung cancer: updated data
from TRUST-1 and TRUST-2. Please make her feel welcome.
Good afternoon, everybody.
On behalf of my core investigators, it is my
pleasure to present telatrexib in TKI-naive
patients with ROS1 rearranged non-small cell lung cancer:
updated data from TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trials.
Here are my disclosures.
Telatrexib is a next generation CNS active
selective ROS TKI, which is currently approved in the United
States, Japan, and China for the treatment of patients
with locally advanced metastatic ROS1 rearranged non-small cell
lung cancer.
We know that telatrexib has shown robust efficacy,
including intracranial efficacy and manageable safety
profile in both TKI-naive and TKI pre-treated
patients based on the Phase II TRUST-1 and TRUST-2
trials.
Here, we report updated efficacy analysis for telatrexib
in TKI-naive patients from TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trials,
together with updated safety data from an integrated
safety analysis.
Here is the study designs.
TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trials were a pivotal Phase II trials,
which enrolled patients with locally advanced or metastatic non-small cell
lung cancer with ROS1 fusion, performance status of zero to
one.
Brain metastasis were allowed if stable.
TRUST-1 enrolled primarily in China.
TRUST-2 was a global study enrolling in North
America, Europe, and Asia
Pacific.I'm going to concentrate on cohort
one in both of those studies, which treated patients who
were ROS1 TKI naive. Patient received telatrexib
six hundred milligrams once a day.
Primary endpoint was IRC assessed confirmed
overall response rate per RECIST one point one.
Key secondary endpoints were duration of response,
PFS, OS, intracranial overall response
rate, and safety.
The efficacy population that I'm reporting includes TKI
naive patients in TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trial with at least
one measurable disease who received telatrexib at six hundred
milligrams once a day.
Safety population includes both TKI naive and TKI
pre-treated patients from phase one and phase two trials
who received at least one dose of telatrexib.
Here are the demographics.
Demographics for this patient population is as expected for
ROS1 rearranged non-small cell lung cancer with high
proportion of never smokers. Majority of the patients had
stage four disease and performance status of one.
Very important to highlight, if you look at the pooled efficacy
population of one hundred fifty-seven patients, that
nineteen percent of the patients received prior chemotherapy and
twenty-three point six percent of the patients had brain metastasis.
Here is the efficacy data. Confirmed overall response rate
in TRUST-1 trial was ninety point three percent.
In patients who received prior chemotherapy, eighty-five point zero.
TRUST-2 confirmed overall response rate eighty-eight point
nine percent and prior chemotherapy hundred percent.
In pooled efficacy analysis of one hundred fifty-seven patients,
confirmed overall response rate was eighty-nine point eight, and in
patients who received prior chemotherapy, it was ninety.
Very important to highlight intracranial efficacy of
the telatrexib. Intracranial confirmed overall response
rate was eighty-seven point five percent in TRUST-1,
sixty-six point seven in TRUST-2, and seventy-six point
five in pooled analysis. Waterfall plot are presented
for you to review. Patients with brain metastasis are
indicated here with green dots.
Duration of response. In pooled efficacy population of one
hundred forty-one patients and median follow-up of
thirty-five point five months, median duration of response
was forty-nine point seven months with lower bound of confidence
interval of thirty-eight months and high bound of confidence interval
not reached. At four years, fifty-three point four
percent of responding patients were still responding.
Same data separated by each trial.
TRUST-1, median follow-up of fifty-one month, median duration of
response of forty-nine point seven months with upper bound of
confidence interval not reached.
At four years, fifty-five point four percent in TRUST-1
trial of patients who responded were still
responding. TRUST-2, median follow-up of thirty point six
months, median duration of response not reached.
Lower bound of confidence interval is twenty point six months and
at three years, sixty point nine percent of patients were still
responding.
Progression-free survival. In pooled efficacy analysis of one hundred
fifty-seven patients, median follow-up of thirty-five and a half months,
median progression-free survival was forty-six point one
month. At four years, forty-eight point nine
percent of patients enrolled in TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trials
were still without progression.
Same data separated by the trial. In TRUST-1,
median PFS of forty-nine point six months.
At four years, fifty point nine percent of the patients were still without
progression.
TRUST-2, median progression-free survival was not
reached with a median follow-up of thirty point six
months. At three years, fifty-five point nine percent
of the patients were still without progression.
Overall survival in TKI naive patients have not been reached.
The lower bound of confidence interval is forty-seven point eight months.
At four years, fifty-eight point four percent of patients were
still alive.
Median overall survival was also not reached when
TRUST-1 and TRUST-2 trials were examined
separately, and confidence intervals are listed for
you on the slide.
Safety. With longer follow-up, we did not see any
new safety signals, and safety was consistent between the
integrated safety population and TKI naive patients.
The most common treatment emergent adverse event was AST
increase and ALT increase, seen in seventy-one
point nine and sixty-eight point three percent of patients
respectively. As you can see, the incidence of grade three
ALT and AST elevations were low at eight point
three and eleven percent.
The raw GI toxicity with telatrexib, diarrhea, nausea,
and vomiting,
all grade toxicities are sixty-four and a half, forty-seven point
nine, and forty-five point two percent.
Similar to the elevation in AST and ALT,
majority of the GI toxicities are grade one and grade two
with an incidence of grade three toxicity is two point five, one
point four, and one point four percent respectively.
It is also very important to highlight that telatrexib
does not have a high incidence of neurological
events.Dizziness was only seen in about
18.5% of patients with grade one dizziness.
2.8% of patients had grade two dizziness.
Dysgeusia, 13.2% of patients grade one,
2.2% of patients grade two.
Treatment emergent adverse event led to dose
interruptions in 42.7%, dose reductions
31.3%, and treatment discontinuation in
8.5%.
In conclusion, with three years of follow-up in pooled analysis
and four years of follow-up in TRUST-1, telatrexate
demonstrates high endurable response rate in TKI-naive patients
with ROS rearranged non-small cell lung cancer with median duration of
response exceeding four years.
To the best of our knowledge, this represents the highest overall response
rate and longest duration of response and PFS
reported to date for an FDA-approved ROS1 TKI in this
patient populations.
This presentation adds 10 months of additional follow-up
since the last report, and telatrexate continues to demonstrate
a manageable safety profile and low rate of
neurologic adverse event.
This data supports telatrexate as an effective, durable, and tolerable treatment
options for patients with advanced ROS1 rearranged non-small cell
lung cancer who have not received prior ROS1
TKI. I'd like to highlight other presentations on
telatrexate today at this meeting.
There is a poster on telatrexate in TKI pretreated population,
as well as some very interesting telatrexate preclinical data.
Also, I'm happy to report that there is a simultaneous
publication in JCO reporting on long-term
efficacy and safety of telatrexate in patients with ROS1
rearranged non-small cell lung cancer, results from a phase
2 TRUST-1 trial.
We would like to thank all the patients who participated in the studies, the study
investigators, and their staff.
These studies were supported by Innovation Bio.
Medical writing support was provided by Ashfield MedCommunications.
And here is a QR code if you would like to get an access to the slides.
And with that, I hope you had a wonderful time in
my beautiful city of San Diego, who I adore, and thank you very
much.
Congratulations. We'll now open for questions.
Please come up to the microphones or submit them
via the QR code.
While people are coming up, I guess I wanted to know, was there any
differences in tolerability between TRUST-1 and
TRUST-2?
It's an excellent question. So there have been none.
So we didn't see any difference in adverse event profile
between TRUST-1 and TRUST-2, and we also presented data
at ASCO 2025 comparing the difference
in side effect profile as well as the efficacy profile
between Asian and non-Asian population. So no difference.
Sorry.
Again, while we are waiting for another question, again, fantastic data.
Congratulations.
So again, there was a greater than 40% dose reduction
for this agent. And was there any dose
optimization done before the phase two study?
There was some dose ranging studies in phase one.
Majority of the dose delays were
mainly from the AST and ALT abnormalities.
None of the patients had to be dose reduced because of the AST and ALT
abnormalities, and they just resolve with dose holds.
I'm quite curious to understand the mechanism of the
lower neurological toxicities, despite the fact it's
very CNS penetrant and had really good CNS
disease control.
A very good question. I'd like to make sure that you stop by
the telatrexate poster, which explains it in very
extensive detail. We think what's happening, so
majority of their CNS toxicity is
probably from the inhibition of TRK B.
And if you look at other oncology drugs that we have, which
have CNS toxicity, like repotrectinib and lorlatinib,
we think that this toxicity is mainly from TRK B inhibition.
And when we look at telatrexate, it only has a partial inhibition of TRK
B, and there is a very big differential.
So it is 11 times more potent
against ROS than it is against TRK B.
And we think that's the rationale why we're seeing lower incidence of
CNS toxicity.
Okay.
Great.
Great. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for the presentation and
congratulations.
And congratulations on the simultaneous JCO publication as well.
So our next speaker is Dr. Shun Lu from
Shanghai Lung Cancer Center,
Shanghai Chest Hospital, Shanghai.
So Dr. Shun Lu will be presenting
SHR-A-1811
plus avelumab as the
first-line treatment for advanced HER2 mutant
non-small cell lung cancer: a randomized phase two cohort from
a phase 1b2 study.
Dr. Lu.
Good afternoon, dear chairperson, and good afternoon, dear colleague.
First of all, I would like to thank the organizing committee to allow
me, on behalf of my co-investigator, to present
atezolizumab, bevacizumab,
SHR-A-1811 plus or minus
adebimumab as a first-line treatment for advanced
HER2 mutant non-small cell lung cancer, a randomized phase
2 cohort from a phase 1b/2 study.
Here is my disclosure.
As you know, trastutuzumab deruxtecan
SHR-1811 is a novel ADC
composed of a HER2-directed
antibody, a cleavable tetratropic peptide link,
and a DNA toposi I inhibitor payload.
Features a potent higher memory permeable
payload and a DAR of six to optimize the
benefit-to-risk profile. In the phase 2
HORIZON-Lung study, SHR-1811
demonstrated substantial and durable activity with a
favorable safety profile in pretreated HER2 mutant
non-small cell lung cancer, supported and approved in China.
Objective response,
74.5% and a median duration of
response, 9.8 months and a median progression-free
survival, 11.5 months. As you also know,
ADC may promote anti-tumor immunity via
immunogenetic cell death, tumor antigen release, and
remoting the tumor microenvironment, providing a
rationality for synergy with immunotherapy.
Here we conduct an open-label phase
1/2 study of evaluate this ADC based
combination therapy in a HER2-mutated or altered
non-small cell lung cancer. Here I report a
randomized phase 2 cohort, cohort D, evaluate
SHR-1811 plus or minus
atezolizumab, which is an anti-PD-L1 IG4
antibody, as a first-line treatment for HER2 mutant
non-small cell lung cancer.
Here is the study design. This is a multicenter open label phase
1b/2 study conducted in China. Patients with local
advanced or metastasis non-small cell lung cancer,
activity HER2 mutation, no private
systemic therapy for local advanced or metastatic disease,
good performance,
at least one measurable lesion per RECIST 1.1
version.
One tool randomization using the
SHR-1811 plus or minus
atezolizumab. The randomization factors
was the PD-L1 expression. The primary endpoint is
objective response. Secondary endpoints including DCR,
DOR, PFS, OS, safety, PK, and
immunogenicity. The data cut-off is October
2025, median follow-up
18.7 months. Patients treated with
combination arm,
36 patients. In monotherapy, 32 patients.
Here is the baseline patient's characteristic.
There is quite a balance between the age, gender,
smoking history, histology, clinical stage,
brain mets, HER2 mutation types, as well as the
PD-L1 expression.
Here is the tumor response. The combination arm got the
objective response
69.4% versus
single arm 81.3%. The duration of response
in combination arm
91.7% versus
monotherapy 93.8%.
Here is the tumor response in subgroup.
Nearly all the patients, regardless of the sex,
age,
ECO performance, brain mets, PD-L1 expression, and the
mutation type, patients nearly all get a benefit, no
matter using the monotherapy or combination.
Here is the duration of tumor response
until data cut-off.
72% of patients in combination
arm still ongoing response, and in monotherapy,
61.5%. That means a median
duration of
tumor response is not reached in combination arm
and in monotherapy 16.6
months.
And here is the progression-free survival.
Until data cut-off,
the median
progression-free survival is not reached in combination arm
and in monotherapy seventeen point nine months, the
hazard ratio 0.65.
Here is the PFS
by the PD-L1 expression. In PD-L1
negative patient, the combination arm, the median
PFS is still not reached. In monotherapy,
17.9 months, hazard ratio 0.72.
Regardless of the patients with PD-L1 positive patient, the
median PFS not reached in both arms, but at a
hazard ratio 0.58.
Here is the safety profile. Generally, the patient
tolerate quite well, no matter monotherapy
or combination. The majority of toxicity is
hematological toxicity as well as some GI
toxicity.
More than grade 3 TRAE in combination arm
77.8%, in monotherapy
40.6%.Serious
TRAE is
19.4% in combination arm and
25 in monotherapy. Regards of IOd,
actually
nearly no difference. Only two patients in
combination arm and one patient in
monotherapy. More than greater than three
IOd, only one patient in combination arm.
So we get to the conclusion.
SHR-1811 plus or minus adebili
as a first-line treatment showed a robust and durable
activity in HER2-mutant non-small cell lung cancers.
The combination arm objective response
69.4%. Twelve months duration
of response rate is 73.8%.
In monotherapy, objective response is
81.3%, and at 12 months, duration
of rate is 70.3%.
Response with this ADC plus
adebili was generally consistent across the subgroups.
Early data suggests a clinical benefit
with additional adebili, regardless of PD-L1
expression, driven by durability of disease
control.
Overall, 12 months PFS rate,
79.2% versus
62.3%. The hazard ratio
0.65.
In PD-L1
negative patient, 12 months PFS rate is
72.2% in combination arm
versus 64.3% in
monotherapy. Hazard ratio 0.72.
In PD-L1 positive patient, 12 months
PFS rate in combination arm is
87.5% versus
60.6% in monotherapy. Hazard ratio
0.58.
The safety profile was manageable, with no new
safety signal noted. Most more than grade
3 TRAEs were hematological toxicity
for both arms. Lower incidence of
TRAEs leading to discontinuation of
SHR-1811,
5.6% for combo and
6.3% for monotherapy. Lower
incidence for IOd. Any grade, only
5.6% for combo and
3.1% for monotherapy. More than grade
3 IOd is only
2.8% in combo and zero
in monotherapy. Follow-up is ongoing.
Further characteristics, long-term outcomes.
Finally, I would like to thank all patients and
their families who participated in this study, all
investigators, research personnel, and the staff
who conducted this study. And also, I want to thank
the study sponsor, Jiangsu Hengrui Pharmaceutical Company.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you so much. If the audience have any questions, please come up to the
mic.
Congratulations on the fantastic presentation.
Again, high response rate in both monotherapy and combination.
So my question is, again, both arms did
well, but the numerical ORR is higher in the
monotherapy arm than the combination arm.
What would be the reasons why the monotherapy arm, again,
small data set,
why there is a difference here?
I think the main reason is still the
samples. This is a very small phase 2 study.
Although the response rate is numerically lower in
combination arm, but you can see the regards of
duration of response, as well as the progression-free survival,
actually, the combination is better compared with the monotherapy.
But still, monotherapy get quite good PFS
and duration of response.
I had a question about, I guess, dose.
Given the rates of grade 3 treatment-related AEs were quite
high in combination, did the trial also look at
potentially a lower dose of the ADC without compromising
efficacy when given in combination with checkpoint?
Thank you. That's a good question.
Actually, we do the phase 1 dose exploration and
also do the dose expansion in phase 1 study, which
already published actually in STT.
And also we already do publish the all phase 2 data
in pre-treated patients
in 兰 州 oncology. From the dose,
we
actually get 4.8 milligram, which we recommend
as a randomized phase 2 data.
The PFS response is higher, much higher
compared with the lower dose, although toxicity a little bit higher.
So that's why actually RP2D, we're using the
4.8 milligram. And we also expansion of
5.6 milligram in expansion cohort.
We found that although a numerical increase response,
but it cannot translate to the PFS, but the
hematological toxicity is much higher.
So that's why actually eventually we're using a
4.8 milligram per kilo as a
RP2D and approve this dose in China.
Thank you so much. Again, terrific data.
One question I had is, it's great we have a lot
of drugs now going after the HER2 mutant cancers.
And five years ago, we didn't have any.
So again, there is no head-to-head comparison.
We can't compare apples with apples or oranges with apples.
But in your view,
how would you compare the treatment-related emergent events to the
combo and mono of SHR versus HER2 mutant
TKIs versus the current approved
antibody-drug conjugate targeting HER2?
Yeah, it's also good questions. As you know, FDA already approved
two TKI and one globally approved
ADC by Daiichi compound. And China
actually will approve the four, including this ADC.
So right now, no head-to-head comparison
in terms of effects as well as
toxicity. So
right now all the approved in second line.
So in first line, very interesting that there is still no
head-to-head comparison. TKI
as well as ADC, all choice
PD-1 plus chemo as a control arm. So
yeah, it's really needed in the future to
identify which is the best.
So actually, we do another phase one study.
In China, Henrui also have
already developed, selected HER2 TKI.
Right now, we do those exploration combination with
TKI with ADC.
Right now, we're already reaching the third dose.
Hopefully, this is at least safe. So in the future,
in front line, I guess that if it's safe, we need a combination
with TKI, with ADC. That will be, I guess, better
than TKI alone or ADC. But at
least right now, in terms of effect, although it's
not a head-to-head, but the PFS is quite similar no
matter TKI as ADC. But I agree, in terms of
toxicity, especially hematological toxicity, TKI is
much better. But TKI has
another toxicity such as diarrhea.
So it's a really unmet need in the future in front line,
which is the best.
Thank you so much.
One final question. Are there any plans to develop
trastuzumab rozatacin globally outside of China?
Yeah. It's also approved in China.
We joined China for
this ADC. But
the trastuzumab,
the Henrui company well-planned the global study,
especially right now we hope that combination with TKI.
That's in the future, maybe. If
our phase one study is safe, we will plan to do the global
study.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, so our third speaker is Dr. Zhang
Hongxe from the First Affiliated Hospital of
Guangzhou Medical University. And Dr.
Xie will be presenting the safety, tolerability, and
efficacy of HS10504
in patients with EGFR mutation-positive locally
advanced or metastatic non-small cell lung cancer: Initial results
from a first-in-human phase 1 trial.
Okay.
Thanks for Professor Liu's introduction.
Good afternoon, everybody. My name is Zhang
Hongxe.
I come from the First Affiliated Hospital of Guangzhou Medical
University,
and it's my great pleasure to present these
preliminary results of the
HS10504 101 study on
behalf of our study team.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
As we know,
the third generation EGFR TKIs
have significantly improved PFS and OS
in patients with EGFR mutant NSCLC.
However, resistance still develops over time,
and most patients will eventually experience
disease progression.
Among different resistance
mechanisms, the C797S mutation
is an important one. It
accounts for about 7% after
first-line treatment with osimertinib and
around 14% after second-line treatment.
Therefore, there is still a clear unmet
medical need.
HS10504 is a novel fourth
generation EGFR TKI, and it is
designed to target C797S mutation
as well as the sensitin mutation, with or
without T790M.
Based on this, we conducted a first-in-human phase one
study of HS10504. Today, I will
present the initial results.
Now let me briefly introduce the
study's design. And this is a phase one
multicenter, single arm studyIt's
eventually safety, efficacy, and PK
of HS10504. The primary endpoint
is MDD or MAD.
We enrolled patients with advanced
NSCLC who had progressed
after prior EGFR TKI treatment.
In dose escalation
stage, doses range of 50
mg to 5 mg once
daily, and importantly,
no DLT was observed, and MDT
was not reached up to 500 mg.
Based on this data, 300 mg and
400 mg were selected for
dose expansion. There were
82 patients enrolled in this phase one trial.
And in this analyze, we include
69 patients in total at 300 mg
and 400 mg from dose escalation and
expansion. This is the largest data set
so far for the fourth generation EGFR TKI.
Now baseline characteristics. We had
34 patients in 300 mg
cohort and 35 patients in
1,400 mg cohort. All patients
had C797S mutation. About half
also had T790M. More
than 60% of patients
received at least two prior treatments.
Overall, the two groups were comparable.
Now let's move to safety. Overall,
HS10504 showed a manageable safety profile.
Compared with 300 mg group, 400 mg
group remained
a manageable profile, though
relatively higher in AE
incidence rate.
In 400 mg group, grade 3 or higher grade
AEs occurred in
65.7%. Only one
patient
discontinued
treatment, which was due to a decrease
of appetite, and no treatment-related deaths
were reported. And most AEs reversible
with supportive care or dose
adjustment.
Okay. Let's look closely at 400 mg group.
In this group, most grade AEs were grade one or two.
Grade 3 or higher grade AEs mainly include
decreased lymphocyte count in
31.4% and anemia in
13.3%.
Most common grade AEs include
elevated bilirubin,
mostly mild. And typical
EGFR-related AEs such as
rash or diarrhea, which
were mostly low grade. Overall, these AEs
were clinically manageable.
And
HS10504 showed encouraging
anti-tumor activity. The
400 mg group performed better than
the 300 group. A cutoff date
December
2024, ORR was
50% for 400 mg versus
31.8% for 300
mg.
And most patients response within two cycles.
Median time to response
was 1.4 months.
With longer follow-up, by March this year, ORR of
400 mg group increased to
52.9% and confirmed ORR
reached to
50%.
Overall, the results are promising and
comparable to other novel treatment options such as
ADC.
And this slide shows that the 400 mg dose had a
deeper tumor shrinkage and response were durable.
Most patients remained on treatment at first data
cutoff. And median PS reached to
9.6 months after longer follow-up by March
this year.
And these further support sustained clinical
benefit of HS10504 at
400 mg.
Also,
we analyzed ctDNA. Blood samples were
collected since baseline,
and 20 patients in 400 mg group
were available. After one cycle,
mutations levels decreased clearly.And this
includes EGFR clinical mutations and
resistant mutations such as C797S and
T790M.
Changes were seen as early as
cycle two, day one,
about three weeks from baseline.
And this shows a fast and strong on-target
effect on HS10504 at 400
mg.
In conclusion,
HS10504 showed encouraging
anti-tumor activity in
C797S-positive NSCLC patients,
and 400 mg was selected as
RP2D, with the ORR was
52.9% and MPFS reached
to 9.6 months, MTTR was
1.4 months.
And the response was rapid and durable.
Safety was manageable with no new safety
signals. Overall, HS10504
is a promising targeted therapy for these
patients with C797S mutation. A further
clinical development is ongoing.
This my all presentation. Thanks all the patients and their
families, and thanks for our leading PI,
Professor Jianxin He,
and all the members in this studies. Thank you very much.
Thank you for your attention.
Congratulations. We'll now open for questions.
Dr. Xie, I was interested to understand of the
patients who got 400 milligrams, there was a
considerable rate of dose reduction.
What were the common reasons for dose reduction, and was it
reversible?
Pardon?
The sound is... I don't listen clearly.
Yeah, just to clarify.
Hi, Dr. Zhang.
Yes.
So she's asking--
May I interrupt?
Yes, sure.
translate
to English.
or
higher
than
300 mg
cohort.
So
the answer is major because the side effect
occurred in our enrolled patients.
Some patients has a
decrease of
lymphocyte count and anemia,
so we'll interrupt the
treatment.
Yeah. It's major for patient safety.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you for your question.
All right. I think we have an audience member.
Please introduce yourself and please ask a question.
And if need be, we have a translator to translate
the question as well. Thank you so much for doing this for us.
Thank you very much. Great presentation. My name is Fabian Ricard.
I am an MD at Daiichi Sankyo.
I'm curious to know, is your drug brain penetrant, and have you seen
any sign of efficacy in your patients with some brain metastases?
I think you had about 10% of patients with brain metastases.
And then my second question is, do you know what's happening when those patients-
Can we do one by one? Sorry.
Oh, one by one. Okay.
Yeah. May I translate?
So
PR,
BT, stable disease today.
Yeah, thank you.
It's a very good question.
In our trial, just 12 patient
enrolled in our analyzed
group. So
the number is limited.
So we are ongoing to analyze
the drug
through the BBB, yeah.
So due to the patient population is limited to 12, so
there's no clear answer to your question for currently.
But we will further
do the data analysis. Now hopefully next ACR, we can
provide more results regarding the patient efficacy data.
Thank you for your great question.
Do we know the brain penetrance from the preclinical data?
No, not yet.
Sorry.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do we know at this point what's happening when those patients
responding to this drug then progress?
Do we know if it's a new mutation that is happening?
available
to share?
Yes, we have.
We can see the
light.
ORR reached to
52.9%.
It's very clear
that they off by March
this year.
So we at least have one patient with a patient shrinkage
percentage around the 50 percentage. Yeah.
For the enrolled 12 patients. That's amazing data.
Okay. I was wondering about additional
resistance mutations that could explain why patients at
some point are no more responding to the study drug, but that may be too early.
And last question, are you planning on doing some
combo with some earlier generation
EGFR mutant TKI?
Now
in this trial is phase one study.
The patient is
not enough to
us
So
thank
you for your great question. It's an early stage for this drug
currently, and we didn't plan any combo at this moment.
But for the phase two or phase three clinical studies, we may
further
explore the study design to combination
therapy in the near future. I thank you so much for your great
questions.
Thank you very much for the presentation-
Thank you
... and translation.
Great. Thanks, Dr. Xie, for your time.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for the translation. That perfectly worked out. Thank you.
Bye, Chair. Thank you.
Hey, to get to the moon, it takes a village, and it takes more collaboration,
global collaboration. Thank you so much.
Language is no bar.
Thank you. So the next speaker is my friend and colleague,
and we trained together, Dr. Kanwal Raghav
from the University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center, Houston, Texas, and he's going to be presenting on the
safety and efficacy of Elirasib, which is
D3S001, a next-generation GDP-bound
KRASG12C inhibitor as monotherapy
or combination therapy with cetuximab in previously
treated metastatic colorectal cancer and pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma: results from a Phase 1/2
study.
Dr. Raghav.
Thank you, Chairs.
The clinical promise of first generation KRAS12C
inhibitors is undeniable.
Yet the experience in GI tumors has been a
study in tempered optimism.
While the current compounds have moved the needle, they've
reached a therapeutic ceiling.
For most of our patients, their clinical benefit is
limited,
of small duration,
and we're still chasing a transformational outcome.
So here are some of the next steps.
I'd like to thank the program committee and my authors.
On behalf of him, it is my honor to present the safety and
efficacy of Elirasib, also known as
D3S001, a next generation GDP-bound
KRAS12C inhibitor in treatment refractory metastatic
colorectal and pancreatic cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
One of the Achilles heels of first generation KRAS12C
inhibitors is the dynamic KRAS cycling and the limited
therapeutic window which the inhibitors have to attach the compound.
Elirasib is a next generation KRAS12C off
inhibitor designed with maximum target engagement
efficiency and outpaces the growth factor-stimulated
nucleotide exchange between the GDP and GTP compound.
It effectively depletes active cellular KRAS with or without
EGF and demonstrates robust preclinical activity in multiple tumor types,
including colorectal and pancreatic cancer.
In addition, it is also CNS penetrable.
In the phase one study,
testing efficacy across different tumor types, it showed a
confirmed objective response rate of
73.5% in KRAS 12C naive
advanced solid tumors. Today, I will present the full
expansion data of the phase one two
trial, including monotherapy in second-line plus
colorectal, combination therapy with cetuximab in
second-line colorectal, and monotherapy in second-line plus pancreatic
cancer.
This study summarizes the clinical pharmacokinetics of Elirasib.
It shows a terminal half-life of eight hours and a dose-dependent
increase in exposure with minimal accumulation.
There is consistent pharmacokinetics seen across mono and combo
therapy arms with the 600 milligrams dose, and the
600 milligrams daily dose achieves four times high
target coverage.
The study was designed as a phase one dose escalation, followed by proof of
concept phase two expansions for patients with locally advanced solid
tumors with documented KRAS 12C mutation
by local testing and who had had at least one line of prior
systemic therapy.
I'm going to concentrate on the results of the cohorts
2C, 1 and 2, and then cohorts 3B. The
600 milligrams daily dose is selected as the recommended phase
two dose for this compound.These are the
baseline characteristics of colorectal cancer patients, 71 of them
being treated with either monotherapy or combo with
cetuximab or anti-EGFR. As you can see, these baseline
characteristics are emblematic of the colorectal cancer population
that is refractory to the standard lines of therapy.
Most patients had liver metastases, and most patients had
received what would be considered standard of care treatments,
including 5-FU, oxaliplatin, irinotecan,
VEGF, and EGFR inhibitor--
VEGF inhibitors and some on salvage line therapies with TAS,
fecotinib, and regorafenib.
The safety profile of the
drug was manageable with monotherapy, showing mostly Grade
1 and 2 toxicities, with Grade 3 or higher treatment-related adverse events
occurring in only 15% of patients in the monotherapy arm and about
48.4% patients in the combo arm. However,
treatment-related adverse events leading to discontinuation or dose reduction were
minimal.
Most of the side effects in the monotherapy arm concentrated around
GI side effects, with nausea and diarrhea, and
some patients showing decreased ANC and lipase.
In the combo therapy arm, the side effect profile was dominated by
anti-EGFR, with side effects of dermatitis,
hypomagnesemia, paronychia, and rash.
This is the waterfall plot for the monotherapy arm across all
doses, including 600 milligrams, which is the recommended phase two
dose. The confirmed objective response rate in this treatment-refractory
population for monotherapy was about
40.5% for all doses and 37.5% for the
600-milligram
dose, with a disease control rate upwards of 80%.
When you look at the SUMERS plot, you realize that most of these
responses occurred very quickly at week six,
and at the time of the data cutoff, about 17.5% patients were
still continuing the study treatment.
The median duration of response for all doses was about 13.1
months, and for 600-milligram
dose was equivalent. The corresponding median PFS was
8.5 months and 9.5 months. While the median OS
is not mature, the 12-month overall survival rate was
81.4% for all doses and 80.8% for the
600-milligram dose.
Coming to the combination. The combination shows
increased amount of response with objective response rate of
62.1% and a confirmed objective response rate of 52%,
with a disease control rate of 96.6%.
Similar to the monotherapy arm, these responses occurred really quickly,
with 55.6% patients achieving their first response by
week six. And at the time of data cutoff, about
27.6% of patients are still on the study treatment.
The median duration of response was seven months, with a median PFS of
8.2 months in this cohort. And while the median OS is
not mature, the 12-month overall survival rate was
92.9%.
Coming to pancreatic cancer. As you can see from baseline
characteristics, this reflects a highly treated pancreatic cancer
population with 43.5% and 26.1%
patients getting one or two lines of treatment
and majority of patients having liver metastases.
The safety profile in this monotherapy cohort for pancreatic
cancer was consistent with the monotherapy in colorectal,
with Grade 3 or higher
treatment-related adverse events of about 8.7%.
Again, the treatment-related adverse events leading to drug
discontinuation or reduction were minimal.
The main treatment-related adverse events here were also nausea and diarrhea, with
a few patients showing AST and ALT increase.
The waterfall plot shows significant responses in patients with
pancreatic cancer in all doses and 600-milligram dose,
with an objective response rate of 69.6% and
65% in the 600-milligram dose, and a confirmed response
rate of 52.2% and 50%,
respectively. The disease control rate in this treatment-refractory
population was upwards of 95%.
Very similar to what we saw in the colorectal cohort, among the 16
responders, nearly 62% patients had their
response at week six scans. And at the
data cutoff, 47.8% patients are still on the study treatment.
The median duration of response was about 10.8 months in the
600-milligram dose, and the median PFS for this
refractory pancreatic cancer population was 13.5 months.
The 12-month median overall survival was
94.4%.
We then concentrated our efforts towards looking at KRAS
G12C variant allele frequency dynamics as measured by
plasma ctDNA,
and we found rapid and deep molecular responses across all
cohorts.
Baseline KRAS G12C was seen in nearly 80%
of patients. And at cycle one,
day eight, you can see that there were rapid and deep responses and
reductions.
There was also a high degree of molecular response rate and even
complete clearance rate in all these cohorts.
And when you look at the CRC mono versus the combo therapy arm, you
notice that the molecular response rate and the complete
response rate in patients with resist CR and PR
were 100% and 76%, compared to 91% and
55% for the monotherapy
arm.Paired baseline
and end-of-treatment ctDNA analysis for patients with PFS greater than
three months was used to study acquired genomic
alterations at the end of therapy.
Acquired alterations in the monotherapy arm were predominantly
secondary KRAS alterations consistent with
previously
reported resistance mechanism for KRAS 12C inhibitors.
In contrast, compared with
elacestrant monotherapy, the combination induced a higher degree
of acquired alterations in the RTK MAP kinase
pathway. These alterations were primarily MET
amplifications, BRAF V600E mutations, and MAP2 kinase
1 mutations. These appear reflective of those
associated with resistance to not only anti-EGFR, but also KRAS
12C inhibition.
In conclusion, elacestrant showed promising efficacy as monotherapy
in second-line plus colorectal cancer and second-line
plus pancreatic cancer, along with combination therapy in
colorectal cancer, with objective response rates ranging
from 47% to 65% and long duration
of responses. The safety profile of elacestrant
remains favorable as monotherapy and in combination with
cetuximab. And furthermore, our data indicates insights into
resistance mechanisms to monotherapy as well as combination therapy,
and these findings will form the basis
of developing novel combination strategies to address resistance
mechanisms,
specifically those that are centered around early emergence
of acquired alterations in the RTK MAP kinase pathway,
more specifically MET amplification and acquired
MAP kinase mutations, which can be amenable to ERK inhibition.
Elacestrant has been granted Fast Track Designation and Orphan Drug
Designation by the US FDA and is currently moving into
pivotal trials as monotherapy and in combination.
I'd like to thank the patients and families that participated in this trial and
the clinical teams that supported it. Thank you.
All right. Congratulations in a fantastic data set.
Again, we will ask the audience to come to the mic to ask
questions.
Hello.
Great presentations. Congratulations to the data.
And please introduce yourself, your name, and where you're from before the
question. Perfect. Thank you.
My name is Shang-Lin Wang from DistroBio.
So I have a specific question for PDAC population because this
data shows great response and durable response.
So now knowing the data from Roemmer about the
recent announcement for the PDAC population for their pan-KRAS, can you
please comment on the comparison of the data, in terms of
PFS versus the OS, but also the future
direction of serial approach for PDAC population in
terms of specific KRAS mutation or pan-RAS mutation?
Yeah, it's a great question. I think that this is the big question in the field,
whether pan-RAS inhibitors are more likely
to affect responses and create that durable response compared to
more allele-specific inhibitors.
I think the verdict is still out there.
It is hard to cross-compare
trials.
However, when you look at that monotherapy efficacy, it rates
favorably compared to the prior KRAS experience in pancreatic
cancer. So, in the absence of a head-to-head
trial, it's hard to come to any conclusions.
But hopefully,
the next steps and the next trials will give you the answer to that
question.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you so much. When we are waiting for the next audience member, I had a
question. Again, impressive data with monotherapy compared to, again,
not apples with apples, again, but compared to other, the prior KRAS
12C drugs, this has activity as monotherapy in
CRC. And the combo data is also good.
So, but again, smaller data set, but when you compare the numeric-- although
the numerical ORR is higher with the combination,
the duration of response and PFS are lower.
Mm-hmm.
So would you envision of a scenario wherein you start with a
monotherapy and add the combo, add cetuximab at resistance
so that you can have a longer duration of
response for the patient and longer duration on the drug for the patient?
Yeah, I think
that's a great observation, Vivek.
I think the difference of efficacy between monotherapy and the
combination therapy are two different questions.
One is a chemistry question, the other one is a biological question,
right? The reason why the drug is more effective as a monotherapy is the
kinetics of the drug are designed to quickly trap RAS in
its off state. And I think that's why it has performed
or at least competitively it performs better than,
say, first generation KRAS 12C inhibitors.
But at some point of time, the resilience of colorectal cancer in terms of
its EGFR feedback loop and development
of bypass pathways tends to occur
irrespective of which drug or which combination you're using.
So I think,
hopefully, in the future, we can combine it with even
other compounds that might decrease those bypass mechanisms, such as
ERK or MET inhibitors.
But I think it's a great question, like could you start
potentially with monotherapy and only use
dual combination in
patients that don't have responses?
I don't know the answer to that question, but...
Thank you so much. Please introduce yourself before asking the question.
Thank you so much.
Kapil Dhingra, New YorkSo one of the things that all KRAS
inhibitors starting from first generation have struggled with is
combinability with the current standard of care as you try to move
them to the first-line setting.
This applies to first generations approved, all the ones being presented
here. So what are your thoughts about potential
combinability of this one, if any data exists or
thoughts in terms of moving it to first-line setting with, for
example, chemotherapy drugs? And if you want to question the fundamental
rationale of even combining with chemotherapy drugs, please feel free to do
so.
Yeah. I
think the data that we have currently as far as the monotherapy is concerned,
the profile appears very favorable compared to first generation KRAS 12C
inhibitors. You saw that in the monotherapy, at least for colorectal
cancer and even for pancreatic cancer, the grade three treatment-related adverse
events were eight and 15% respectively in
colorectal and pancreatic.
It does render the drug very favorable from a point of
combination with not just chemotherapy but other drugs.
However, when you start combining it with anti-EGFR drugs, the
predominant safety profile is guided by that anti-EGFR moiety.
So I think that further rational combinations will have to balance
risks and benefit of that combination.
But in colorectal, at least so far, our experience has been
that combination with chemotherapy
effectively only increases the duration of response for targeted
therapy, as evidenced by Breakwater study with BRAF.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you so much. Thank you, Dr. Raghav.
Thank you, chairs.
Okay, so far in the first few talks, we've been looking at
precision oncology through a genomic lens.
So we're now going to move higher up in the cellular stratosphere and be
exploring precision oncology through the tumor microenvironment and
novel protein targeting strategies.
So with that, I'd like to introduce Dr.
Terri-Ann Koch from Amplia Therapeutics, Australia,
and she will be presenting on namifotenib in combination
with gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel in first-line
patients with advanced pancreatic cancer, the ACCENT trial.
Good afternoon.
I'm delighted to be able to share the ACCENT data with you today.
In full disclosure, I am an employee of Amplia Therapeutics.
So just to introduce the focal adhesion kinase,
the enzyme is overactive in pancreatic cancer, and this
overactivity leads to worse patient outcomes.
And this is because FAk is a cellular stress buffer that
sustains the tumor survival, especially under
therapeutic stress.
FAk's overactivity, not only in the cancer cell itself, but also in
the tumor microenvironment, causes fibrosis and
immune suppression.
It increases tumor growth and metastases as well as
treatment resistance,
which is why Amplia has been developing namifotenib,
a small molecule that's highly potent and highly
selective for FAk. Its pharmacokinetic
properties is an oral once a day with great dose
proportionality.
Its patient population is not limited by the molecular profile.
It's safe to combine with a number of medications
because of its low risk of significant drug-drug
interactions and its ability to combine with a broad range
of the standard of care therapies.
There is evidence of FAk's target engagement, both pre-clinically and
clinically. And today, I'm going to be presenting you
the ACCENT trial in advanced metastatic pancreatic
cancer. It's a Phase 1b/2a study that was conducted
in Australia and Korea. The objectives of the study
was to determine the safety and the efficacy of
namifotenib in combination with gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel in patients with newly diagnosed
metastatic disease. The primary endpoints were safety and
tolerability and ORR, defined by RECIST 1.1,
and the additional endpoints are progression-free survival, overall
survival.
Before I go into that, I just wanted to outline the dosing
strategy for namifotenib. In the ACCENT study, it
was defined based on the preclinical efficacy data.
It wasn't defined for many safety concerns.
The intermittent dosing schedule was to give namifotenib orally
once a day, seven days before the first chemotherapy on day one.
Chemotherapy, gemabraxane nab-paclitaxel, is
given as the standard of care on day one, day eight and day
15.
And four days before each of the chemotherapies, each cycle,
namifotenib is given orally.
Twelve out of the 28 days, the patient sees namifotenib or takes
namifotenib, which is a 43% coverage with this intermittent
dosing schedule.
The demographics of the trial from part A, it was the dose
escalation, dose selection phase.
Three patients were dosed at 100 milligrams once a day,
three patients at 200 milligrams,
and we stepped up to
nine patients at 400 milligrams. And this was the dose selected for
expansion in part B,
the single arm non-blinded Simon two-stage design,
where a further 55 patients were given 400 milligrams
of namifotenib.So we've taken all part A and part
Bs, 400 milligram patients, 64 of them.
From this patient demographic, you can see 52% were
in Australia and 48% in Korea,
almost a 50/50 split with males and females.
And the one other thing I'd like to point out is that 67% of the
patients have an ECOG 1.
Now, just to introduce the data today that was presented
in the abstract, was based on the investigator-read
resist data. Today, I'm presenting to you the
independent review centrally-read data
based on two independent experts blinded to investigators in the
clinical data.
We wanted to start off with the safety.
Namifotenib's treatment results in negligible
extra patient burden,
which is seen here in the table. Adverse events grade
3 or above, you can see compared to the two pivotal
studies, the IMPACT study and the NAPOLI study, such as
neutropenia, 39% in combination with
namifotenib and gem/nab-paclitaxel compared very
comparably to 38% to 39%. As you go down
the column, you'll see very comparable with the standard of care.
In addition to this, namifotenib's treatment-related
events were mostly gastrointestinal, predominantly mild to
moderate. You can see from this table, which characterizes
namifotenib-related adverse events of any grade greater than
5%, nausea was the most common at around 30%,
followed by vomiting and diarrhea at around 20%.
So overall, namifotenib had
a well-managed safety profile.
So I'm really excited to share with you our
efficacy data here today based on the centrally read.
We had five complete responses in our metastatic
pancreatic cancer patients, which is around 8%,
compared to our benchmark trial, the IMPACT trial, of
0.2, a 40-fold increase. And in addition to
these complete responses, we had 18 confirmed partial
responses, which also included one pathological
complete response.
The confirmed objective response rate was 36%,
compared to IMPACT's 23.
And the disease control rate was 70%, well
above IMPACT's 50.
Twelve of these patients were treated for over 12 months, and I just want to
mention the study is ongoing, and four patients are still on trial.
So looking at this data in more detail, our best responses
really show the enhanced depth of response with namifotenib in
combination with the chemotherapy.
On this graph, you can see the reduction in tumor volume on the
Y-axis going down to 100%. Our five confirmed
complete responses at 100%
reduction highlighted here in purple,
our pathological complete response in orange, and the
partial responses are in blue.
The average tumor volume reduction is almost 70%
reduction. So we're really seeing enhanced depth of response.
When we look at this depth of response over time, it really
highlights the sustained deep tumor shrinkage and the
durability of namifotenib in combination with the chemotherapy.
If you look here on the Y-axis, the
reduction in tumor growth, the first
complete response was seen as early as the second
cycle
and was sustained throughout. Other complete responses took over six months,
and some of them were even occurring as late as 12 months, really
demonstrating that sustained tumor reduction.
Some of the partial responses, and these patients with open circles are
still ongoing in the trial, you can see here are almost out
to 24 months, over 600 days on
study.
This translates to an improved PFS, a progression free survival,
currently determined at 7.7 months, is substantially better than
the chemotherapy alone of gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel
of 5.5 months. The overall improvement was greater
than FOLFIRINOX also at 6.4 months.
This did translate to improved overall survival of 11.1
months,
which compares very
favorably to gemcitabine nab-paclitaxel at
8.5 and 9.2 months,
and comparable to FOLFIRINOX at 11.1 months.
And when you break this down at best overall response, you can really see the
benefit these complete responses have had.
Of the five patients, one patient has passed, but the other five
patients are ongoing and are well over 12 to 18 months.
So taken all together, today I've had the opportunity to show you the ACCENT trial
data
and the deep and the fast response namifotenib has in combination with the
chemotherapy. Five patients of complete response,
18 patients, including one partial
pathological complete response, an improved progression-free
survival of 7.7 months,
which has resulted in a durable and sustained response.
Twelve patients have been treated for over 12 months and an improved
overall survival of 11.1 months.
This deep and sustained response for many patients has
been demonstrated in combination with good tolerability
profile with a minimal additional patient
burden.So in ACCENT, namifodunib was
given intermittently. And in subsequent studies and moving forward
with pivotal trials, we'll be utilizing daily
dosing,
which we believe, which we hypothesize will further enhance this
efficacy.
I'd like to acknowledge all the co-authors on this trial and thank the
investigator and the site staff. We also gratefully acknowledge the
patients, their families, and their loved ones for their contributions to
these trials. Thank you.
We'll now open for questions.
Dr. Kok, I was wondering, the really interesting
efficacy signals that you see, is there a reason that you
chose gem abraxane and not FOLFIRINOX as the
chemotherapy partner? And do you think that this could be combined with other
chemotherapy agents?
I'm sorry.
I didn't hear.
Yeah. So with the choice of the chemotherapy
backbone being gem abraxane, some patients are
treated with first-line FOLFIRINOX.
And do you think this drug can synergize with
FOLFIRINOX chemotherapy?
Absolutely.
Ampler is also conducting a trial, AMPLICITY, in
combination with FOLFIRINOX.
Mm-hmm.
That trial has been going well, and it has
demonstrated the patients can tolerate the combination.
Unfortunately, the FOLFIRINOX side effects, the study
has been put on hold. But the preclinical data does
show that not only gemcitabine,
nab-paclitaxel, FOLFIRINOX also synergizes well-
Mm-hmm
... with namifodunib.
We have an audience member with a question.
Please introduce yourself and where you're from, and then ask the question.
Thank you.
Duane Demong, Merck Research Labs. A very nice talk.
I had a question. Could you elaborate on the rationale
for using intermittent dosing? And have you assessed
phospho-FAK levels pre and post-treatment
in tumor with any
of the patients in your cohort?
Certainly.
Intermittent dosing was
a concept developed from preclinical efficacy data
using a model which was a very short-term model.
We've since done a lot of work preclinically and demonstrated the
optimal dosing strategy is with continuous dosing in line
with the other FAK inhibitors which are in clinical development.
The second part of your question, have we demonstrated target engagement?
We did this in the
phase one study in healthy individuals and showed target
engagement at 100 milligrams. Since we've then gone on,
unfortunately, the assay
failed for us in the phase two study, so we didn't get a
chance to analyze those samples because the assay was no longer validated.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
When waiting for the next audience member-
Ah, we've got a question
... please.
Yep.
Okay. I'm Xu Gaoyang from China CSPC
Pharmaceutical Company. And I have a question that, from
the presentation, we can see that there is a
priming dose regimen. So
I think it is very important for the
clinical development. So based on what evidence
or
clinical data or preclinical data you designed
as
priming dose regimen. Thank you.
Thank you for your question. The priming was designed
based on the preclinical data showing the anti-fibrotic effects.
So the concept was by treating the tumor for a short time
before the chemotherapy,
pancreatic cancer is known for having fibrotic tough shields.
So by treating the tumor before the chemotherapy, you can
maximize the anti-fibrotic effects of
namifodunib and improve the chemotherapy
and namifodunib's entry into the tumor.
Yeah. I think from the mechanism of action
perspective,
it works. But
what the duration will be
performed before
the chemotherapy and the immunotherapy combined
to provide the chemotherapy and the
immunotherapy combined therapy prior to the priming dose,
how much the time?
How much?
How much the time? What
is the accurate duration? For
seven days? Ten days? So how to determine it?
Our understanding of fibrosis in cancer, it's a very fast and dynamic
changes, unlike the classic
long-term chronic fibrotic diseases.
So it's believed, and based on the preclinical work, that a short
priming of
four to seven days would be long enough to have that beneficial effect.
Unfortunately, the biomarkers around fibrosis clinically
are not able to validate this for us at this stage.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
All right. We have another question.
Yes, please. Very nice data. Thank you very much.
Very interested in the safety of the combo.
You have shown, I think, peripheral neuropathy 6% compared to
20% in the
prior studies for the gem abraxane and maybe
higher in some other studies. So do you think that you have a
preventative effect on the peripheral neuropathy, as it
has been reported recently with the FAK inhibitor?
I think we need more data to make any of those claims.
I think it's a small subset. We'll continue looking at it and
hopefully that will have that reflection
Okay. Very interesting. Thank you. Thank you so much.
I have just one more question. Again, impressive complete
responses in pancreatic cancer. Again, more and more we have a lot
of RAS inhibitors, KRAS inhibitors in pancreatic cancer.
So again,
for this data set, do you have any next-gen sequencing data on the
patients for their RAS and BRCA status,
at least?
We are actively getting that now, and we are just as excited as you to see those
results. It's very important to look at. We fully appreciate that.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. And the next speaker we have, Dr.
Valentina Marulanda Corzo
from the Weill Cornell College of Medicine, New York.
The presentation is titled, "Phase 1 Dose-Escalation
Expansion Study of Fractionated Dose and Multiple Cycle
Anti-PSMA-Targeted Alpha Emitter
Actinium-225 J591."
Good afternoon. Thank you, Dr. Vivek, for the kind introduction,
and thank you to the organizers for the opportunity to present our
work today at this mini symposium about clinical
trials.
I'm presenting on behalf of Dr. Tagawa, and I would like to take a
moment to thank him for
giving me the opportunity to present here.
And with that being said, I'll present our study.
It's a Phase 1 dose-escalation expansion study of
fractionated dose and multi-cycle anti-PSMA-targeted
alpha emitter with actinium-225 and antibody ligand
J591. I'm Valentina Marulanda, Research Fellow
at Weill Cornell Medicine. These are my disclosures, none of them
related to this presentation.
So a little bit of background. The role of PSMA in targeted
regional therapy is well established, and
PSMA can be targeted either using small molecule or
antibody-based ligands, and these can be radiolabeled
with either beta or alpha emitters.
The differences between antibody ligands and small molecules,
and antibody ligands compared to small molecules circulate
longer in the bloodstream, which allows them
to find and bind to their target for more time
in the order of days compared to hours.
And there are also some differences between alphas and betas.
So alphas compared to betas have high linear
energy transfer compared to betas, and they also have a shorter
range in tissue compared to betas, allowing the
concentration of cytotoxic
damage to tumor cells, sparing healthy tissue.
There's also a benefit of this complex in alpha
therapy and antibody ligands is that once it's
internalized, it stays internalized for longer as compared
to the small molecule ligands, which allows for more
concentrated and targeted therapy, more importantly in
those patients who have a small volume disease such as bone metastatic
disease.
So today, I'll focus on the right side of the screen looking at the
antibody ligand J591 and the alpha particle
actinium-225. So this work builds on the
prior first-in-human Phase 1 single-dose escalation
trial. And important about this trial is that the maximum dose
tolerated was not reached, and the recommended Phase 2 dose
was established at the maximum dose tested.
So the purpose of this trial is to test the safety of two
regimens at differing levels of administered radioactivity
of PSMA-targeted alpha radionuclide with actinium-225
and antibody ligand J591.
So essentially, this trial was a two-in-one
trial design. The first regimen studied was a
fractionated dose-dense regimen.
It was a single cycle given on day one and day
15. And the rationale for this design or
for this schedule was first to
decrease the window for tumor
repopulation and tumor resistance, but also to
decrease toxicity and increase efficacy
with a dose-dense approach. The second regimen that was
studied was a multiple cycle, and this was given in up
to four cycles of the study drug
within six weeks, one after the other.
And this interval was chosen for mainly two
reasons. First, to allow for the blood count
to recover after NADIR, but also considering that the
current schedule for lutetium PSMA is also
under a similar regimen, preserving the potential for
future combination therapy approaches.
And then after a protocol amendment,
a third cohort was established within the same fractionated
cohort for those patients who had received prior lutetium
PSMA under the hypothesis that these patients had
different response outcomes.
So the primary endpoints that we looked at in this study were
DLTs and recommended Phase 2 dose establishment,
and secondary endpoints included PSA response, radiographic
response, survival outcomes, adverse events, and
quality of life.So first, let's define dose-limiting
toxicity. We use the standard criteria for dose-limiting
toxicity and any grade toxicity that
delay the next administration. So for the fractionated cohort,
any delay of more than two weeks in the second
administration met criteria for DLT.
And for patients treated in the multiple cycle cohort, more than
three weeks delay in any subsequent cycle
was also considered a DLT, which is substantially
different from other trials. So in total,
we enrolled and treated 60 patients,
42 in the fractionated arm, 23 patients in
the dose escalation arm, 11 patients in the expansion
arm, and eight of these patients had received prior
lutetium PSMA. And in the multiple cycle regimen, we
enrolled and treated 18 patients.
Note that before the amendment, two patients in the
fractionated cohort and one patient in the multiple cycle
cohort also received prior lutetium PSMA.
So in terms of demographics, our cohort had a median age
of 73 years old, and most of the patients were high
risk prognostic group according to CalGB criteria, also
known as Allaby risk, Allaby nomogram.
As expected, most of the patients had metastatic bone disease,
and note that this was a heavily pretreated population.
Most of the patients had received prior chemotherapy and at
least one androgen receptor pathway inhibitor.
So what did we find in terms of DLTs?
In the fractionated cohort, 34 patients treated, three
patients presented with DLTs, all related to thrombocytopenia.
Two of them had grade four thrombocytopenia
at levels of 60 and 65 kilobecquerels per kilogram
without clinically significant bleeding, and one patient had grade
two thrombocytopenia that delayed
day 15 administration.
So this led to the establishment of the recommended phase two dose at
60 kilobecquerels per kilogram, and patients in the expansion
phase were treated with this dose.
For those within the fractionated regimen that had prior lutetium
PSMA, eight patients were treated, and two of them had
dose-limiting toxicities at 50 kilobecquerels per kilogram,
again, associated or attributed to thrombocytopenia, and
one of them also had grade four neutropenia.
There was no bleeding or clinical sequela.
And in the multiple cycle cohort, seven patients had
DLTs across all levels administered, all
also attributed to thrombocytopenia.
And in this regimen, it is not recommended for further study,
at least not at every six weeks intervals.
This is a table with the treatment emergent adverse events.
These are the most frequent, organized from most frequent across
cohorts and grades. And we can see how there's a
predominance of the hematologic toxicity in the top
half of this table and a couple clinical adverse
events related predominantly to fatigue and
pain.
In terms of antitumor activity in PSA response, most of the
patients, more than 70% of the
patients had PSA response. And when looking at those
who had at least 50% decline in their PSA as compared to
baseline,
fractionated cohort
both with and without prior lutetium had about 60%
PSA response, and 30% of these patients in the
multiple cycle cohort reached this cutoff of PSA 50.
Secondary outcomes, we look at circulating tumor cells
with CTC count, and 60% of the patients also had
CTC response. And when looking at radiographic
response using RECIST criteria,
77% of the patients had controlled disease, and
the fractionated cohort had 20% of the patients who
had partial response.
Now, moving on to survival outcomes, progression-free survival
defined as first progression by PSA, radiographic criteria,
or death. Here we can see the Kaplan-Meier curves and
how the fractionated had a longer progression-free survival,
although the differences were not statistically significant across
cohorts. And when looking at overall survival, the median overall
survival of our cohort was almost 12 months.
Here we can see the Kaplan-Meier curves.
And when we performed multivariable analysis,
considering, of course, that the design of this study
was not designed to do cross-arm
comparisons, when performing multivariable analysis, the
fractionated cohort demonstrated
statistically significant prolongation
in overall survival.
So in conclusion, the dose administration of
actinium-225 with antibody ligand J591 is
not recommended in the multiple cycle cohort, at least not at
every six weeks.
And the fractionated dose-dense regimen demonstrated
favorable safety profile and promising preliminary
efficacy in patients with metastatic advanced prostate cancer, both
with and without prior lutetium PSMA small
molecule.
So something to highlight about this study is that it represents a
successful transition from academia to industry.
Currently, a biotech company named Convergent is
completing a phase two study in both pre and post lutetium
PSMA patient population using the fractionated regimen
at the recommended phase two dose
and also a registrational phase three
planned.I would like to finish this
presentation thanking our teams and collaborators at Weill Cornell
Medicine. This is definitely a multidisciplinary
effort. Thank you to our funding sources, and most
importantly, to patients and their families.
I'll leave you with the conclusion slide, and thank you all for your
time and your attention. I'm happy to take any questions.
Yes,
open for questions. And congratulations on such an impressive
investigator-led study in one center and the really impressive
results.
Thank you.
Can you tell us a bit more about patient-reported outcomes?
You did allude to this, as one of the endpoints was quality of life.
I know we're limited by time, but do you have any results?
Yes. And thank you for bringing up.
That's very important because we don't do anything if we are not
improving patients' quality of life.
So we did assess this with the functional assessment
cancer,
self-reported outcomes for prostate, and then after an
amendment, after radionuclide therapy.
And we saw that there's at first, first four weeks
to eight weeks, there's a decrease in this course, but then
there's an increase at progression.
So we see that we are improving not only safety
and efficacy, but also quality of life of patients.
And unfortunately, these patients do progress, and that is
also what we are seeing in patient-reported outcomes.
Please, we have an audience member with a question.
Thank you for the talk. Very interesting presentations.
Just one question regarding your recommended phase two dose.
I'm not very familiar with this type of
radioligands. So can you comment on your selection of the dose?
Because I haven't seen any dose response or exposure response.
Can you,
just a little bit of elaboration on how you decide your recommended phase two dose.
How we establish the recommended phase two dose.
Yeah.
Okay. So
we started by doing three plus three
design. So if patients didn't have any dose limiting
toxicity in three patients, then we had another three
set of patients with an escalated dose.
If they didn't have any adverse event, then we kept scaling
the dose until we had, if a patient had,
within these three patients, one of them had a dose-limiting
toxicity, then we would expand to three more to have
a total of six patients per dose or
radio administered radioactivity.
If two patients within those six had dose
limiting toxicity, that was considered the maximum
tolerated dose.
So the recommended phase two dose was below that.
So for example, in the fractionated arm, we had two
patients within six patients treated in total,
that had dose limiting toxicities.
So below the sixty-five, it was the sixty, and that's how
we determined that sixty was the recommended phase two
dose, because just one patient in that group of patients
had DLT. This led to the expansion phase, which as I
mentioned, was eleven patients. So if we add the
eleven patients plus the six patients in the dose escalation,
it was 17 patients. And of 17 patients, just
one had the dose limiting toxicity.
That was clear, but my question was mainly, how did you decide, fifty
or sixty or fifty-five? How this was decided?
Okay. Yeah.
Thanks for your question. So this was based on the prior single dose
escalation trial that was already published and that I
referred to in the first couple slides about
background. So the maximum tolerated dose was ninety-three point
three kilobecquerels in just one single dose.
And based on those results and dosimetry to other
organs, that's how we established that we would start with
forty-five and scale up.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you for your question.
We have another audience member. Please introduce yourself, where you're from, and
then the question.
Okay. Tzu-Chien Chung from Honeybee Biosciences.
I would like to ask, did you use any imaging
tools to select patient? And,
since actinium-225 have some daughter molecules,
have some
imaging, did you try to imaging to
see the progress for the patient?
Yes. So we did perform PSMA PET at baseline
and then 12 weeks after the first therapy.
And although PSMA PET was not used for treatment selection
or eligibility criteria, it was used as a biomarker.
And we do have assessment of this based on
receipt, but I couldn't share
it because ten minutes for a six years
clinical trial is just not enough.
But I'll encourage you all to stay tuned.
The paper is soon to be published, so make sure
to check it out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your question.
Thank you very much. Congratulations.
And it's always hard to execute these challenging
radiopharmaceutical studies. I say to my colleagues that
the pill-based studies is just like
vocal singing,
but these radiopharmaceutical studies are putting like a huge grand opera
together.
Yeah.
Like multiple moving parts. Multiple. So again, congratulations.
And then more impressive is the academic to industry transition.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Sure. Thank you all.
And last but not least, I'd like to introduce and invite Dr.
Patricia Larusso from the Yale Cancer Center, Yale
University. She'll be talking about a phase 1,
first-in-human, multicenter, open label study of
ZW191, a folate receptor alpha
ADC in patients with advanced solid tumors.
Hey, gang. How's it going?
You can tell that I'm no longer the president, but the past president, because they
gave me the absolute last presentation- ...
clinical trial presentation of the meeting.
But on behalf of my co-investigators, I would like to thank the organizing
committee for allowing us to present to you today the results of our phase
I trial of ZW191.
My disclosures.
ZW191 is an antibody drug conjugate that binds folate
receptor alpha, which is highly expressed in many advanced solid
tumors, including ovarian, endometrial, and non-small cell
lung cancer, with limited expression in normal tissue.
As you can see from the cartoon on the
right, this antibody drug conjugate has a novel
topoisomerase I payload that was designed
specifically by Zymeworks for this antibody drug
conjugate linked to the monoclonal antibody by a
protease cleavable linker with a drug antibody ratio
of eight.
This slide depicts the entire study schema, but what I'm going to be
focusing on today is the part one component of the
schema. Part 2A is currently ongoing in terms of
recruitment. Part one is the dose escalation
component of the trial that
had key eligibility, which included
adults with a good performance status of zero to
one with
either platinum resistant ovarian cancer, endometrial
cancer, or non-small cell lung cancer that had
exhausted available treatments.
Folate receptor alpha expression was measured
retrospectively.
In this trial, we began at 1.6 mg per kg dose escalated
all the way up to 11.2 mg per kg. I point out the
6.4 and 9.6 mg per kg dose because those were the
two doses that were incorporated into part A dose
escalation component of the trial,
which is ongoing and recruiting
ovarian cancer patients. The primary endpoint for our trial
was safety and tolerability, identification of the maximum
tolerated dose, as well as the recommended dose for
expansion, with key secondary endpoints being activity,
pharmacokinetics, and immunogenicity.
Today, what I will report on is the part one safety and
efficacy results with a median follow-up of seven
months and a data cutoff date of March 9th,
2026.
This slide depicts the demographics and baseline characteristics.
But what I'd like to point out is that roughly two-thirds of the patients that were
recruited had ovarian cancer, roughly 25%
had endometrial cancer, and five patients recruited had
non-small cell lung cancer.
This slide depicting prior systemic treatment identifies
this patient population as heavily pretreated with a
median number of prior treatments in the metastatic setting of three,
ranging from 1.1 to nine.
Both the platinum resistant ovarian cancer cohort as well
as the endometrial cohort enlisted patients that all had
been exposed to prior platinum and taxane in a
metastatic or advanced setting. In the
endometrial cancer cohort,
over 90% of the patients had had prior checkpoint inhibitor, and
in the ovarian cancer cohort, over 80% had been
exposed to prior bevacizumab, roughly two-thirds
a PARP inhibitor, primarily in the maintenance setting, and
there were two patients recruited to the trial that had prior exposure
to mirvetuximab.
This slide depicts the safety and tolerability in terms of treatment
emergent adverse events.
I'd like to focus primarily on the two doses that were escalated
into part 2A.
As you can see, grade three treatment emergent adverse
events occurred in 33% and 67% of
patients. Serious adverse events, 25% to
50%. Treatment emergent
adverse events leading to dose delays, roughly
50%, leading to dose reduction up to
25%, and leading to discontinuation, there were
two patients in both cohorts. However, regarding these
last three characteristics, these
characteristics of TEAEs
leading to changes in dosing occurred after several cycles
of therapy.
There were two patients in total that had dose limiting toxicities.
One patient at the 6.4 mg per kg dose that had
anemia, and one patient at the 11.2 mg per kg
dose that had thrombocytopenia, diarrhea, and
sepsis.
This graph depicts the bar graph of
TEAEs that occurred in at least 20% or more of
participants, blue being any grade, green
being grade three or greater. And as you can see
on this bar graph, the main grade three or greater
toxicities were primarily myelosuppression.
But overall, this bar graph I feel depicts a very
well safety profile of this
drug administered in this study with the most common greater than
equal to grade 3 AEs, as you can see, all being
myelosuppression in this number of patients in
this trialThis graph is
comparing both the 6.4 versus the 9.6
mg per kg dose. Again, blue being any grade,
green being Grade 3, and orange being Grade
4. And what you see is that there was only one Grade 4
toxicity myelosuppression,
thrombocytopenia. And if you
folded this graph
in half, what you would identify is that most of the toxicities
between 6.4 and 9.6 were relatively
superimposable in terms of type of toxicity as
well as the degree or the
percent of toxicity.
Here we see the antitumor activity in the 34 patients
recruited with ovarian cancer. What you see in the
waterfall plot is significant antitumor activity
with many patients, as you can see by these black arrows
continuing on trial. The overall response rate in the
ovarian cancer population across all dose levels was
56%, but in the dose range of relevance
that led to the dose optimization doses,
the overall response rate was 61% with a disease
control rate of 100% in this population.
What's also very interesting, if you look at the spider plot, is the depth
of responses in these patients with, again,
many of the patients, based on the arrows,
continuing on trial at the time of data
cutoff.
Looking specifically at folate receptor alpha expression,
the degree of expression did not at all correlate with response.
Patients with low expression,
as you can see, had
significant antitumor activity, as well as those with high levels of
expression.
Here we see the cohort of patients with endometrial cancer in
terms of antitumor activity. Again, all
patients had
endometrial cancer with low folate receptor alpha
expression. The overall response rate across
all dose levels was 40%, but in the dose range of
interest, 57%, with disease control
rates exceeding 80%. And again, you see the
depth of the responses in this spider plot.
Looking at the swimmer's plot to identify duration of treatment and overall
response, we see a significant percentage of patients still
maintaining response at six months, with many of the
patients having not been on treatment long enough, but continuing
on therapy. Again, we see long response
rates regardless of, as you can see, across multiple dose
levels. What's very interesting is that the median duration of
response in both the ovarian cancer as well as
the endometrial cancer cohorts has not been reached.
The median progression-free survival in both ovarian and
endometrial cohorts was 7.6 months.
However, the
upper
limit of PFS has not yet been
reached as of the data cutoff, many of these patients
continuing--
Due to the
number of patients continuing on trial, the
actual range could not be identified because of
continuation on therapy.
Pharmacokinetics
identified
a relative increased exposure in a dose proportional
manner for all three analytes.
Kinetics at cycle four
was slightly higher than the kinetics that was identified at cycle
one. And following first IV infusion, the
concentrations declined with a mean terminal half-life of the
total antibody of approximately six and a half days, and of
the antibody conjugated payload, approximately six
days.
So in conclusion, ZW191, I feel
demonstrated a broad therapeutic window and competitive
efficacy in both high as well as low folate receptor
alpha expressing tumors, justifying further
investigation both as monotherapy and in
combination. The compound was well-tolerated and
safe, and safety through the high dose of
administration or the upper dose of administration, which was
11.2 mg per kg. In the dose range of interest,
6.4 to 9.6 mg per kg, there was compelling
efficacy regardless of folate receptor alpha
expression in this heavily pretreated population.
Again, with the median duration of response not reached and the median
PFS
in both ovarian and endometrial cancer at minimum
7.6 months. As stated previously, the Part
2A dose optimization is ongoing at the
6.4 and 9.6 mg per kg doses.
And finally, I would sincerely like to thank the patients, the participants
and their families, as well as the investigators, especially
the clinical trial staff and Syneos
Health, who helped prepare the slides for this trial.
Again, this trial is a global study and
is ongoing at 27 sites across multiple
regions, including North America,
the Asia Pacific, and Europe. Thank you.
Thank you so
much, Dr. Pat Larusso. Again, it's a pleasure, honor, and privilege to have the
former AACR president present-
For the last clinical talk of the meeting.
I think they had it as the last presentation because they have the boss and the
principal so that the kids stay back.
A few people, at least.
Yes
Hi, Kapil Lingren, New York.
Hey, Kapil. How are you doing?
Good, Pat. Since you were the last presenter, we had to all stay here as-
I know.
That's strategic.
I know. It's painful, right?
So it's really a comment, but I would like your reaction to it.
So I think your data clearly shows that the Ventana test,
as it's being read out, is not appropriate for this drug.
Because you're seeing so many responses in so-called low expressers,
but the definition of low expressers by the Ventana assay is zero to
twenty-four percent with two-plus, three-plus staining.
And you know where I'm going with this.
It's very reminiscent of what happened with Kadcyla versus enhertu.
Original test was three-plus in more than 10% cells
until enhertu starts working in so-called low hertu expressers.
So as you guys think about pivotal trial and Phase II
expansions, it may be worthwhile to revalidate the
assay. And instead of looking for zero to twenty-four percent,
two-plus, three-plus, perhaps we ought to be looking at what percent have at least
one-plus, and that may prove to be a better predictor of efficacy
because the drug is obviously so targeted, it shouldn't work if the folate
receptor expression is zero.
Point well taken. And I'm sure they're looking at other assays like
protein levels, et cetera. There's some really amazing
assays that are moving forward across the spectrum,
necessarily so because of antibody drug conjugates and their
targets relative to efficacy and response.
And just quickly, I'm not criticizing the assay per se.
I think it's more about how it's being read out-
How you're reading the assay
... and revalidating.
Thanks, Kapil.
Again, the same question, right? Beyond the assay could be the
payload as well, because mirvetuximab is approved with a DM
payload. Maybe for TOP1 payload, you don't need
folate receptor testing in these patients, especially with ovarian
endometrial cancer.
That I cannot answer. I do believe that this is a better
payload, though. We have a lot of TOPO payloads, TOP1 payloads.
But this is, I think, a unique payload that may lend
itself, but you may be right.
So do you think would it have activity-
And remember, mirvetuximab didn't respond in anything other--
Well, the vast majority of responses weren't folate receptor alpha high.
People do use it in intermediate and low.
I don't necessarily know if that's the right thing to do over and
above sending them for a clinical trial, but it is used
in.
So because mirvetuximab is approved in folate
receptor-positive patients, do you think this agent would have activity post that
because it's a different payload?
Well, the two patients that had mirvetuximab both and
progressed both responded. Oh, yeah, you have a totally different
payload. It's like giving two different chemotherapies.
Absolutely. But actually, I think this is pretty good data when you look at
mirve versus this, so pretty exciting.
Thank you.
Thank you all so very much.
Oh, do you have a question?
Yeah, she had a question.
Oh, that's okay.
Sorry.
I was going to ask about combination therapies.
You see really impressive objective responses, but there is some
toxicity. Where do you see clinically combination therapies
being brought in upfront or upon progression, and
what combinations?
Well, it depends on where they're going to position the drug.
But obviously, we have the typical IO
combinations.
You'd have to do a Phase I to be able to determine whether or not you
can combine it with other cytotoxic
therapies. But especially in endometrial cancer, where we did
see a response rate, I think a decent response.
Instead of giving it after an immune checkpoint inhibitor, it makes a lot of
sense, especially in that cohort of patients, to give it in combination
with an immune checkpoint inhibitor.
There would be probably very little overlap because ILD was not a
real issue in our trial like we've seen with other ADCs.
Right.
All right. Thank you so much, Dr. Larusso, and thank you so much to the audience
for staying.
Dr.
Jenny Liu has a few slides for conclusion.
As I said, we all want to go to the moon.
I think we got the seats and buckled up the seats, so
we are waiting to go to the moon.
Dr. Liu.
Thank you.
Thanks everybody for staying back, and I'll just be closing with a few
high-level overviews aligning with the theme of
the AACR meeting, precision, partnership,
and collaboration. So as you can see, precision
is really evolving very rapidly, and nowadays we are seeing
breathtaking efficacy with multiple third and fourth
generation TKIs demonstrating durability
and also exceptional CNS control.
We're looking at novel therapies that are targeting
resistance biology and also mechanism-driven
combination strategies, looking at the tumor microenvironment
and harnessing the immune system.
What we've heard from the talks this afternoon is that partnership is now
global and collaborative. 50% of the talks in this
session
enrolled patients from multiple regions around the world.
And we saw a beautiful example of partnership between
academia and industry with investigator-led
studies.
And thirdly, combination therapies targeting the
microenvironment and immune system is required.
So the scale and speed of progress that we see today is
only possible through this collaboration.
But the most important thing, though, is purpose.
How can we advance our science to benefit patients?
We can see that across multiple studies, there is a trade-off
that when we give patients combination therapyDespite increased
efficacy, there is also increased toxicity.
And the key question in the clinic is which patients can we get away with
monotherapy and which patients do we need combination therapy up front?
Quality of life is really key, but only one of our studies
reported on PROs, and this is probably something we need to be doing more
intentionally and earlier in drug development as the
quality of our drugs improve.
Thirdly, the real issue of the gap between trial
success and real-world access. And the reality is
that globally, only 5% to 7% of
patients access clinical trials.
And while 60% of patients have actionable genomic
alterations on next-generation sequencing in the real world,
only a quarter of those patients actually receive matched
therapies.
I want to also spend a moment to mention the invisible
participants. Those are the patients whose screen fail
during trial workup.
Those are the patients that deteriorate on waitlists because there aren't
enough slots to accommodate the patients needing novel therapies.
And also those who have rare cancers and who are never
eligible for therapies because of the definition of
eligibility for current trials.
So moving forward, I think we need to be integrating dose,
schedule, and patient experience into precision
oncology, and also advancing the way we are doing
biomarkers and incorporating more novel and
multi-omic biomarkers to better predict efficacy
and toxicity.
And finally, meetings such as this shows the really
exciting number of pipelines coming through.
But what I hope to see is that we can use data from clinical trials
as learning systems, and we can take learnings from one pipeline
to others in order to help patients.
Ultimately, we are no longer limited by drug discovery.
We are now limited by our ability to select, deliver,
and sustain benefit for the right patients at the right time.
Thanks so much to all our excellent speakers, and on behalf of
Vivek and myself, we'll now close the session.